Probably no surprise that Donald Trump
has been the subject of over 2100 CNN
reports since he announced his candidacy
for president on June 16th.
Okay.
Maybe 10,
2100 is a little bit surprising,
but the basic calculus is something I
think everyone cynically understands.
Trump gets ratings.
The news carries a little less obvious
is that trump's high poll numbers are
actually a result of his outside
coverage in the media.
Political science professor John Sides
has produced a number of handicrafts
that show the correlation between
trump's share of coverage versus his
poll numbers and it's pretty conclusive.
What's more,
if you graph all the job candidates,
polling numbers,
verse their share of coverage,
you get a correlation of point nine six,
close to a straight line as I've ever
seen.
Of course you could say causation moves
the other way here.
That whole numbers drive coverage and in
some way they do.
Only news coverage usually comes first.
People hear a lot about a candidate
research that can they identify in the
same way that you do when you hear a pop
song on the radio over and over and over
again,
and that exposure ultimately means
they're more likely to give that name to
pollsters.
The news then reports more on the top
candidates,
which means even more coverage,
which means even higher polling and it
becomes a cycle that perpetuates itself
until the top dog makes a mistake.
It's three agencies of government when I
get there that are gone,
commerce education and the uh,
uh,
what's the third one there?
Or a new fresh face,
steal some attention away.
Women all over this country heard very
clearly what Mr Trump said.
The problem is that trump's mistakes are
often so inflammatory,
newsmaking that they worked to his
advantage,
and new fresh faces are the ones that
trump attacks the hardest,
listened to her for more than five
minutes straight.
You get a headache.
Twenty 100 news stories later.
And here we are.
We know why the news works like this.
Less ratings mean less ad revenue means
less.
Profit means lower stock prices means
fewer investors,
means layoffs in America who indeed in
the global economy,
everything always has to grow the news,
especially Cable News,
has a vague interest in keeping its
dependence on capitalists.
Incentives under wraps,
even though everyone knows that ratings
to a large part determined the news,
news organizations have to tout their
journalistic integrity,
even if it's only a formality and this.
This might just be the gift that Donald
Trump is giving to all of us more than
anything I can remember.
The trump phenomenon strips away the
false righteousness of the news media.
When trump does something outrageous,
CNN doesn't cover it by choice,
but because they are forced to do so,
the trump phenomenon strips away the
false righteousness of politicians to
trump has cooperated political language
and employed it to such a ridiculous and
shameless degree that it's emptiness is
laid totally bare,
and lastly,
trump strips away the false
righteousness of us,
the American public.
The second gop debate was the highest
rated program in the history of CNN.
CNN is forced to cover trump because we
forced them.
Why?
When we put on something with Jeb Bush
talking about the economy or Scott
Walker talking about labor unions,
why doesn't anybody watched that?
It's in our nature to gravitate toward
confirmation bias and sensationalism.
It takes a force of will to consume
media that may be bored,
but crucial for making intelligent
political choices,
and in large part,
it's a mental muscle that most of us,
myself often included,
don't want to exercise.
Donald trump exists at the nexus of all
these things and his invocation of all
three is I think an important lesson.
The news media politicians and the
general public are all responsible for
the existence of Donald Trump and no one
of these things is going to change
drastically overnight,
but if all of them move just a little
bit in the right direction toward
integrity,
honesty,
and engagement respectively,
the difference could be substantial.
We know that the news media is biased
and politicians talk bullshit and the
news and the politicians know,
we know it still.
They go through the formalities.
It is exactly formalities like this that
can keep the system alive longer than it
needs to be.
So maybe we need someone like Donald
Trump to pull down that last layer of
credibility.
How are you going to create jobs in this
country?
I'm just going to do it.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
We heard about $950 on the patron,
which is $50 away from the big goal of a
thousand dollars that starts to make
this financially feasible for me.
So if you like the nerd writer have you,
there's something you don't think you're
seeing somewhere else on youtube or the
Internet.
Pledge a little bit money for the
project and we can do a lot of more
stuff.
There's no more stickers or mugs left,
but I want to order some more swag,
maybe some more mugs,
but I'd like to hear what you would like
of nerd writer swag and that universal.
Let me know in the comments and we'll
we'll get some and put them up.
Thank you so much for watching and I
will see you guys next Wednesday.